it's one thing to be on that list um I
even sat down with Dr Dre about weed
before really yeah like face to face
yeah what was the face to face Dre
meeting like crazy cuz that's really for
someone who grew up in uh I told you
give I I told you I would give you gems
on this because I [__] with you you're
very consistent with like caring about
my story but like yeah shout out to slim
the mobster man
um he made a call back in the days yo
slim the
mobster [__] he was on aftermath he was
in jail and he made a call and from jail
was on the phone and and I went and went
to go sit down with Dre they was like no
man he ain't here man he ain't here they
was like shooting me away I was like man
slim I'm here bro ain't try he's like
hold on boom boom boom and I get let in
and I go sit down and uh Andre sat down
with me and I and I showed him a jar of
what we wanted to call The Chronic and
it was by far the best looking weed
we've ever
produced it was incredible beautiful it
was orange purple funky stanky just buds
looked it was like it would looked like
it was out of a [__] movie how good
this weed looked I showed him the
chronic and he was just like yeah I [__]
with it and I appreciate slim putting
this play together and you know we'll
think about it but like I don't know if
I really want to kind of put myself in
the industry you know I I got you know
he told me I got money money and I don't
really want to play with that until you
know maybe it's federally illegal I just
don't want to risk it I'm like what year
was this this was
like like three or four years ago oh
[__] so not too far not too long ago
yeah um and I said I respect that and I
said can I leave this with you for
yourself or those who smoke he's like
for sure I got like a nervous picture
with him Fred wck took the picture for
me cuz he was there shout out to Fred
wck uh but yeah I think it's cool that
like being on that hip-hop list I think
it's cool because like Dre saw me he had
to see you like oh that's I remember
that guy yeah I remember that guy he
pitched me on this we I guess it's going
pretty well yeah I guess it [__]
worked for him I think it's cool cuz I
got a chance to share moments with Diddy
and I got a chance to share moments with
Jay-Z and the top four yeah and I didn't
get I've never met Kanye you know I
don't know whatever I have no opinion on
that but I'm just saying it's cool
because I've ran into all those guys and
I felt good for them to see me up there
because I told them what I wanted to do
and what I was building at the time and
now they see they have to see the list
they're like oh [__] cuz the same guy
that does their evaluation and is kind
of making sure that you know their their
their net worth is credible and relevant
is doing mine so it's real you know I
was going to say when that happens what
is the um whether it's the forb or that
list what is like the influx in people
just in your DMs or bothering you or all
of a sudden trying to [__] with you it's
got to be crazy it's crazy bro it's
crazy I'm not the answer to anyone's
problems I promise you or just like I
would just see people like like posting
that would just never ever like post
about you or like even like acknowledge
your music or what you're doing and it's
like oh now you know now you know this
guy's on the cover of Forbes and now you
know you're [__] I mean it's kind of
cool you obviously the more successful
you get the more people are going to
come to the party they're going to come
they're going to come and like recognize
game but like again for me just it's
life goal [__] because I grew up looking
up to Jay-Z I grew up looking up to
Diddy who didn't right grew up looking
up to Dr Dre kany is [__] no matter
what anyone says about the guy he's a
[__] he's a legend bro he's he's a
smart guy he buil he built out easy hard
and so like it's cool to sit next to
those guys it's cool to like be
acknowledged by the same guys that
acknowledge Him on a wealth um you know
side things but like [__] I just felt
good when that came out I was like damn
I talked to multiple of these guys I
told him what I wanted to do I think the
coolest thing is bro I'm just getting
started yeah like we just I can't say
what but Vibes just locked in something
so big no The Vibes papers are going
crazy I feel like it's I mean I feel
like it's very hard to take off the top
dog and I feel like you guys have done a
really good job of like like if I go to
any smoke shop it used to be if I went
to a smoke shop and I saw Vibes oh you
guys got Vibes that's [__] sick you
know bur's my friend that's cool
it's everywhere yeah but like the play
we just locked in for Vibes is so next
level bro like and you know you guys
will see it two years from now cuz I
probably won't be able to talk about it
for a while but like it's one of those
plays that like goes down in history bro
and so like I'm just getting started so
if I made that list now right it's crazy
cuz this
alone is a [__] a a beast of a
business yeah Vibes is about to hit hard
so like you know when I I feel like
cookies is nowhere close to where it's
going to be especially because we
haven't really added International as
much as we could possibly in the future
so it's crazy cuz you've dealt with so
many uphill battles in every single one
of these spaces you're in like
especially like I remember when you you
had the public falling out with Josh at
Raw because it if it feels like if I'm a
guy who has a company that depends on
weed users and burner comes into that
space I'm freaking the [__] out because
I know it's going to work yeah well
especially like if I come in that space
and I get next to key players that
actually make that business what it's
about to be because I started getting
next to everyone real quick yeah real
quick like I didn't just say white label
of rolling paper for me I went and found
the best rolling paper producer I went
and found the best specialty item
producer like the Cali the the you could
have done any you could have been lazy
and and did what a lot of people didn't
just white label some [__] yeah yeah we
ain't doing none of that and so the fact
we start getting close to real people I
I think made other rolling paper
producers feel the threat but that
threat shouldn't have been felt until
today because the the document that came
through my email today is serious yeah
[__] better feel that threat
because I'm coming for the top space in
rolling paper business and I say that
with confidence with my balls hanging
down to my feet right now you know what
I mean